kann ich jetzt buchen oder muss ich mich
noch gedulden
herr andere check was sagen sie kann ich
bei tui jetzt schon meinen sommerurlaub
buchen oder sollte ich lieber warten
ich kann selbstverständlich aktuell
schon buchen jedoch wie hört man ja das
sagte führen wir aktuell keine reisen
durch die slots sind wir aktuell in
kontakt mit unseren partnern in den
zielgebieten sprechen genau darüber wie
könnten wie das geschäft hochfahren und
wir könnten wird dafür hat sich aber das
sicherstellen dass unsere kunden sich
durch licht oder filme mit allen den
vorsichtsmaßnahmen die
höchstwahrscheinlich auch dann geboten
sein werden wenn es wieder losgeht also
angefangen von masken an bord der
flugzeuge und boote der transfer
einbusse es geht weiter um das thema
wollen wir weitergehen paket anbieten
beim essen anders ist eher besseren die
kunden weniger miteinander in kontakt
kommen die weit außen könnten gelegen
aufgestellt werden damit jeder die sonne
genießen kann und so weiter und so fort
alle diese maßnahmen in vorbereitung und
werden aktuell besprochen und werden zur
anwendung kommen sobald wir gehen in
geschäfte ging tatsächlich die frage ist
eine reise findet statt das ist ja schon
mal die erste gute nachricht die zweite
ist natürlich wie es dann mit dem spaß
also haben gesagt die liegen müssen
auseinander stehen partys finden
vielleicht gar nicht statt
vor ort sind vielleicht auch noch
verschiedene sachen geschlossen welcher
mit welchen einschränkungen muss sich da
leben ist urlaub plötzlich total anders
nun es wird ein anderes sein dass davon
können wir ausgehen
sicherlich wird es nicht so sein dass es
wieder pool partys geben wird oder
insgesamt partys das diskotheken auch
haben es wird andere urlaub aber
vielleicht des lenkungs erholsamer denn
es wird
keine massenansammlungen geben dürfen
die kunden wären sicherlich weiterhin
darauf achten zu recht
kontakt also abstand zueinander zu eine
zweite behalten
die ich vorher sagte liegen und
insgesamt zufrieden da kommt man
zueinander
aber wie gesagt das wird ein bürger oder
denn es wird auch sicherlich die haut
weniger ausgelastet sollte man wird
vielmehr seine domain genießen können
und tatsächlich entspannen können